hello everyone this is the secret life
of what everyone this is the secret life
of pons and today we're going to take a
look at games where we have rigid pawn
structures in broken games so the first
one I want to show is the classical game
between Capablanca antartic over this
classical game and this will be very
important to know for future reference
and the future games I'm going to show
you the 486 well the opening doesn't
really matter it's actually the
Stonewall variation but we're mostly
headed towards the endgame and that's
the point where you're more interested
in here me6 classical stuff 94 exchanges
now White has doubled pawn but it's
compensated that the idea of efore
breaks so White has fairly good chances
to get an advantage although it has the
problem of having these double Ponda as
a disadvantage yay for the ship takes f3
well even though this is not our main
topic but just getting rid of your
bishop for no reason is usually not a
great idea so I would say that knight c6
must have been much better but whatever
[ __ ] took over played Bishop takes f3
takes knight c6 Ruby one okay that's
just fast-forward to the important part
g3 King f8 and peanuts just stop here
this is kind of a critical position for
the game cup of lung cathartic over and
even though there's no direct threat
that Capablanca can do in this position
but he still needs to come up with a
plan here so what type of plans could
white come up in this position yeah we
can as you point out we can put a lot of
pressure on this guy or make a second
weakness now chess is a game of
decisions we have to decide which one we
want to do see if I could be a little
bit risky in the sense that our king
will get a little weak as well yes h4 h5
and actually capablanca played g2 and
now h4 he played the preparatory kingi
to first just to make sure that there
won't be any checks in the upcoming
future and after that he played h4 now
as pointed out h5 is the threat but it's
also grabbing some space and asking the
question from Torchic over what are you
going to do about it
so tirta cover decided to do some action
and if your opponent plays on the side
you usually play in the center so you
play d5 capablanca has to take because
for example white is not careful take
stakes and then this nasty check would
double attack both the bishop and the
king so that's a no-no what cup of
Blanca is a great player he doesn't fall
for these cheapos so it takes on d5
takes d5 takes six six takes
and how they kappa blanka continued here
still age five of course if you start a
plan you try to continue with that okay
up six total Cooper doesn't want to take
on H five because then Luke age one
comes and then Capablanca would just
take all the pawns and might even look
at the d5 pawn as well let's say C six
which looks a bit weird it does defend
the d5 pawn though but then in that case
the h7 pawn will fall and that's a
problem so Torchic overplays recap six H
takes H takes rook h1 hmm okay let's
stop here how could we assess this
position with white do you be like yeah
those still win why do you feel it's
close to one yeah so for one thing is
pointed out correctly that the knight is
stranded on a five black also has
weaknesses on g6 this rook is entering
the seventh rank we have two pawns
against one and we have a bishop against
the night in an open position so
capablanca should be able to win this
position so Brooke h1 King f8 okay seven
rooks c6
but TARTA cover is fighting he's trying
to have some ghost threats and saying
those threats because rook takes c3
doesn't really threaten much because
bishop g6 then these pawns start rolling
and then it will be over so dr. Cooper
can never take on c3 so he brings his
knight back to the game g5 this g5 idea
feels kind of similar to the idea played
between lost care against the same guy
who's white Capablanca just making sure
that this pawn on g6 will become an
eternal weakness
so Tara took over it gives a check King
f3 Knight f5 in here cuppa Blancas that
choice what to do I should buy proceed
in this position
and so one idea is to take on a five and
just March up with the king
yeah black was defending quite well
though because now rook takes c3 is a
real threat yeah and the d4 pawn also
Falls as well so indeed Papa Blanca
chose to take G takes the King g3 and
we'll see that even though black will be
a pawn up that doesn't really matter
that much engage for rook f3 I should
might continue here g6 so in general in
these rook end games it's really the
quality of the pawn that matters and not
the quantity and also the skiing is way
superior to this passive King on f8 rook
at for King g5 rookie for King up six
and now this is very very uncomfortable
for black one thing rook e8 is made but
also this pawn is very very close to
promoting so tour took over played King
g8 checks first so he asked this
decision because the king is too well
placed on g8 he wants to know where Tata
cover wants to bring that king as if
King f8 that's kind of running into a
potential check with g7 and if h8 then
mating ideas will be up in the air so
rook takes c7 already we have the second
threat of mating rook e8 game takes f5
and again now material equality is
restored but there are huge differences
between the activity of the pieces
this rook is a demigod on the seventh
rank this King is just monstrous on f5
well these black pieces are pretty bad
rookie four can get six notice that
anytime black tries to get active
Capablanca says no no and forces black
to go back to passive defense rook F for
King me five room G for
how did capablanca continue here ya g7
check a little bit of calculation
because obviously the g7 just loses a
steak steak scheme d5 and after king c6
the pawn starts rolling and that's an
easy meant for white so King g8 was
forced Luke takes a seven and now all
the pawns fall and black is just
ultimately lost Brooke c1 king b6 and
black is just waiting but time is up and
the pawn just promotes so that was a
very nice textbook way of playing this
and games and one of the big students of
capablanca is Korchnoi Korchnoi loved to
study all the grades
and he always noticed these little
intricacies that Capablanca and other
greats used in their games so this is an
early encounter in fact between Korchnoi
and Karpov they played it in Soviet
championship that's a few years before
they actually played their match
so Karpov played h6
and obviously we can see that white is
much better for quite a few reasons can
we mention a few of them
yeah the pawn on e6 is extremely weak
the structure is just amazing for white
and we have this very good ePHI pawn
just pushing black to the seventh and
eighth rank also notice that rook takes
e5 which would be a neat little tactic
doesn't work because of route takes d7
check and if you take it with either of
those pieces you just lose a piece so h6
displayed now we'll have to find a good
plan for Korchnoi
whenever we get these bind kind of
positions we'll have to keep in mind
that our opponent badly wants to
untangle themselves so we kind of trying
to keep the cat in the box the king yeah
but what is Karpov aiming with that h6
move anybody help me that what does he
want with that partly waiting but when
you have little to no space you want to
gain some and that's actually what
Karpov is looking for he's kind of
hinting at g5 I'm not saying that this
is a brutal threat that Korchnoi really
has to worry about but it's a way of
gaining space so Korchnoi doesn't like
activity from his opponents so it plays
h4 so he keeps Karpov in the box okay
eight and now rookie three you can't
really go to g3 right now because the e5
pawn is a bit hanging but it never hurts
to have a threat like with g3 rook c6
and now comes the tough question whether
we should exchange or not
fortunately decides not to exchange and
in fact that's kind of a rule if you
have more space exchanges favour the one
who has less space so fortunately wants
to keep as many pieces on the board as
possible
rook c5
oxi five and he changed his plan which
is kind of surprising I guess you
realize that this pressure on e5 is just
too annoying so he has no other choice
than to change his plans in exchange
instead but Korchnoi still follows the
plan of pushing black off the board
how did court do that
yeah room g3 so already hitting on g7
also planning a move of rogue g6 which
is not a big threat but it's a threat
so Brooke g8
rook g6 I assume Bishop d7 or something
yeah yeah
in fact Viktor Korchnoi did it
immediately when King after yeah and in
the upcoming moves we'll see that King
yes that plus one more temple and also
we'll see them can go and just win the
battle for the whole light army g5 King
III Korchnoi is confident that nothing
is going to happen on the King side
because he has full control black can
never take because of the Brooke
dropping and also g4 would just create
another weakness for Karpov but he had
no choice and played g4 anyways but
fortunately keeps on marching king d4 h5
king c5 and we can see again the
differences between the king will decide
this game otherwise it would be roughly
even because neither of these rooks are
too good
both of them are fairly passive this
should be four can be six and again in
this active King which you should all
only do when it's an endgame otherwise
this would be fairly risky to do it's
kind of powerful because the only way
black can defend this pawn is to move
the rook there Bishop d3 Bishop f5 rook
III so Viktor Korchnoi his plan is now
simple he wants to get rid of the
bishops and then go around with the rook
but sometimes plans change and then he
would never want this rook to enter his
position so therefore he cuts off that
line
Bishop c2 king b5 rook e8 rookie - but
he slowly does the manoeuvre anyways now
he plays g3 so the pawns will all be on
black and then this way Karpov will
never have any chance to gobble them up
Bishop a5 rogue d2 and there's very hard
to stop ideas of rook d6 rook a6 and in
fact that just happens and wins the game
king b6 rook d7 takes King takes before
and one pass pawn is not the end of the
world but when they're two connected
once that's just too much gay v g1 rook
C 2 G 3 ok to just use using the old
classical method of supporting the
passed pawn from behind so the pawn can
freely launch forward while also
defending against a g2 move rook h1
Karpov is quick to give up on the idea
of g2 cuz after a six there's no way you
can push this Jeep on cuz I would just
take the pawn on g2 I mentioned before
so he plays rook h1 a6 takes King c3
okay h3 some little tricks but it don't
work and after rook g2 the spawn is just
way too advanced and it's just going to
promote in the upcoming moves so Karpov
resigned so all in all let me learn from
the first two games it's very important
to activate your King because it might
be the only way to win the position so
let's take a look at
match Korchnoi Karpov which was played
in 1978 and yeah oh yeah and this one
will be a classical Orthodox system
which is very solid but slight bit
passive these are just the main moves
it's all theory the ship takes f6 Bishop
takes f6 and in fact Bishop takes f6 was
preparing an idea which is very
classical in these type of Orthodox
structures can anybody tell me what is
that
it's the classical idea of minority
attack yes of course
so the idea of minority attack just to
launch forward the pons and probe for
weaknesses Bishop g4 92 now usually very
easy and we give our Knights away for
bishops but technically this is a closed
position so coronally decides to keep
the Knights instead rook c8 and now
Fortuner comes up with a very
interesting concept there not many white
players know in this type of position
it's not necessarily a hard move but I
don't see too often can anybody guess
what chord I played here
yeah Bishop f5 so yeah pretty
straightforward but it's in fact I feel
a rare idea usually why thinks that this
bishop is a burden for black but is also
a very good defender when it comes to
defending the c6 pawn so fortunately
decides I want to hit these weak spots
so I play Bishop f5 get rid of your best
defender and just play on your
weaknesses Queen d7 mean takes d7 of
course is not afraid of getting into an
endgame he's confident that he'll be
able to squeeze this position to the
maximum a for Bishop e7 you're not
giving that pawn for free Knight f6 in
here fortunate comes up with a concept
not as known at that time he will not do
the regular way of attacking the
position b5 but he'll go
a5 and the plan will come clear very
soon a 6 and we can already sense that
this b7 pawn will become extremely weak
in the long run now it's not an easy job
getting close to that fumble but we'll
have to do yes the regular plan of
jumping to a form and then to c5 to
capture this important square bishop f8
night c5 rookie 7 obviously Karpov is
not even thinking about taking because
that would be the end of it I'm just
going to double here and this weakness
we'll just prove fatal for black so
Karpov stays put and defends the b7 pawn
and now Korchnoi shows something that
you know modern days is not so usual
he shows signs of patience he knows that
he has constant pressure in these
positions so he need not rush and he
keeps to his plans 98th coming up with
this classical plan of posting the night
on d6 where it will be very well place
kingi to ID 6 King bee 3 so I made this
position slightly better for white
maybe equal but what is the one pushing
and trying to probe for more weaknesses
in blacks position now the first
question is how can we probe in this
position that white it's more of a
strategical position so we can think
long term here what will be the ultimate
plan for white to open up the position
what will be the crucial breakthrough
well yeah
what will push some pawns to get some
space
but there's one pivotal square that
white will need to have a firm grip on
no v6d fight well d5 is protected OB 5v5
not really because that's very very
protected by those pawns so we're not
going to be able to cross through there
if v is a bit far away but we're getting
closer
we'll have to make a pawn break
yeah b5 doesn't really work so which
square there's the square that is kind
of guarded by our Knights
efore any yes even though not the knight
on d6 and the rook on e7 has some
pressure on it in the long term white
will have enough resources to push
through there but as a big of a
professional Korchnoi is he will wait
till the last second to make the break
efore rook e8 rook e1 it's just the
first sign that I'm defending this pawn
I'm not telling you if I'm actually
gonna play f3 yet but maybe maybe it's
in the air g6 rookie to have sex rook a
e1 just defending everything and seeing
what Karpov is doing Bishop h6 Karpov is
heavily preparing against the idea of e4
Knight b3 bishop f8 but it's tough to
play this position with black bow
because all of the pieces black has is
optimally placed now he will have to
find waiting moves that don't ruin the
position so Karpov feels that
everything's in order
I'll just go back to f8 92 Bishop h6 h3
Korchnoi
stops jumping around with his horses and
decides that the night on d2 will be
better off plays there as it will
support the idea of e4 being up 7 g4
just as mentioned white is gaining some
space on the kingside bishop f8 f3 and
as the bishop moves away he plays the
move f3
rook d8
so Karpov changes tack and he's trying
to jump to b5 and hit on the potentially
weak square of D for in an event of e
for now it's not necessarily working but
it might dissuade Korchnoi well course
no he feels that he has a lot of time so
he's moving around with his Knights a
little bit more and b5 rook f1 Bishop h6
f4 gaining even more space and might
even dream of ideas of g5 or f5 to pin
down blacks position now if I would be
even better because in that case then I
can jump to e6 and have that lovely
square used as an outpost for the Knight
f4
Bishop f8 92 96 rookie 186 rook f1 just
waiting would be eight okay one okay and
now as Karpov moved his rook from that
great square Korchnoi decides okay I
achieved the ultimate position it won't
be any better than this so it's time for
efore move another 41 so after like 20
moves of waiting he decides yeah that
they also have sealed move at this
moment but he was still patiently
grinding Karpov in this position waiting
for the right moment to break yes but it
is true thank you for mentioning that
at this moment there was such a thing as
a sealed move so Karpov wouldn't know
quartz nice move and it and he will see
the next move that will be played on the
next day
an envelope and the arbiter will open it
up and show that it was e4 and at this
moment seconds would be preparing for
potential lines that would be played in
1978 so times are changing seconds are
doing more works with computers now e4 D
takes e4 in 94 and now white is still
better than we can state that because
this night is just eternally better than
this Bishop on f8 so maybe it's not that
much of an advantage but it's something
that corner will try to nurse to victory
night b5 night c3 so Korchnoi senses
that there'll be too much pressure on
this pawn on d4 so he plays Knight c3
and gets rid of this nasty nasty beast
on b5 take C to take C to Bishop takes
e5 notice that Karpov seizes the best
moments to get rid of that pesky knight
on c5 for that very passive bishop on f8
takes rook d8 might be 5/8 X b5 and we
reached the endgame and we're getting
very very close to the endgame we first
saw between Capablanca antartic over
obviously it's a different structure but
we'll learn later why it's important to
know these great predecessors so he
plays f5 takes takes and the idea of f5
is potentially creating a weakness on h6
also kind of playing against that King
on f7 because if white would make a
hasty move like rook a to I could
potentially start rolling in with the
King with the idea of king d5 or just
with the simple plan of coming over
and that the position would be near or
close to equal therefore fortunate plays
f5 take six rook g8 trying to get active
in c3 rook e8 rook d2 why this Court
should I play rook d2 what is the plan
fortunately is looking for here yeah
yeah he needs he needs to open some
lines but he also wants to get into a
rockin game as you mentioned if we
exchange rooks is just a drawn end game
so it plays rook d2 rookie for King V
for now that's the reason it's useful to
learn about other games from great hand
game players because we will guess the
best move from court law in this
position what did Korchnoi play here
in fact if we think about it it kind of
mirrors the position of Capablanca Tariq
over a six of course and the scorchin
are learned from his studies his nothing
is important than having an active King
so he gives them up the pond just to get
a king closer to this week's e6 pawn
also the King has had it to be six King
these seven Karpov is trying to oppose
that but he is one temple short and the
King comes to be six before how should
we continue here push yes palm push d5
takes takes king c8 and even though
Karpov managed to find a good spot for
the King it's still in danger just like
in the game between capablanca antartic
over now in real game games it's not
that easy to play those positions
because you have to nurse your own pawns
while also stopping any potential pawn
moves by your opponent how did Korchnoi
managed to do both
yeah route d3 and now rook d3 is
important for two reasons one of them is
obviously to stop the spawn from
marching what could be the other reason
yes
to activate the rook because apart from
having an active King it's very
important to have an active rook so
black played a5 which wasn't good he
needed to play something like rook c4
and rook c3 and then Karpov would have
some type of chances of surviving
although it's already a tough position
if you don't have a computer because all
of coronary species are very well placed
and it takes just few mistakes for a
Karpov to get in big trouble
so a5 what was porch noise next move
yeah it is either c6 or room cheese feed
that is the big yeah he didn't do both
he decided between one of them so why
would you March the palm it would apply
a little more pressure why would you
bring your work to g3 instead of pushing
the pond yeah yeah both of them look
very dangerous but I like the fact that
why played rook g3 and I think the
reason why this is very strong now cuz
in endgame stampy's are very important
if whatever I'll just make a
demonstrative move h5 is obviously not
the move to play here but if I check c6
will come with a check and that's very
important and rook and games that every
move you make is the forcing moves
therefore you can gain some time so if
you play c6 immediately you won't get
that extra tempo meaning rook g3 forces
Karpov to do something right now if you
play c6 like it's not forced to do
anything at the moment but rook GC g3
with the idea of rook g8 will force
black to react so he plays beats me
and now Korchnoi comes up with a
brilliant move and which I think
surprised Karpov king c6 yes and many
times people think that it's just about
pawn races in rook and games but it's
not the case in fact in Brooklyn games
playing with your king is as important
as being strategic with your pawn
movements king c6
and now the problem is for black that he
either goes back
Ruki 8 but then I'll just take your pawn
and then you'll have miserable pieces or
if you move your king I'll be able to
take and again threaten ideas of rugby 8
and start marching my pawn of either
King d5 or King b7 and c6 c7 so this is
very dangerous for black already so king
c6 again puts Karpov in and some sorts
of suits long so he plays King b8 takes
King a7 and in fact this King be a king
a7 plan was again high class usually in
end games on the fifth rank they say
that you should bring your King to the
side and that's just what Karpov does
rugby 7 check now rugby 7 check is
always a question if it's a good move or
not at the moment
black obviously wouldn't want to bring
his King to a8 but after rugby seven
quartzion asks the question so you want
to post your King on a 8 that would be
terrible for you though but if you go to
a 6s he does then Korchnoi pins attempt
E which would be 6 check now and again
he wins a pivotal tempo that will win
him the game engage 7 give me five and
we can see that with every little checks
and moves Korchnoi gained a little bit
of momentum and that's how he outplayed
slowly Karpov in this game now the game
is basically over and as soon is going
to end because Cochin is just about to
gobble up all the pawns Black has a four
takes rook at four takes it's just too
many pawns and it's not dry enough
because this King is very active again
while also this King is kind of far away
specially from this square and actually
flag decided to resign here which is
understandable as I can just start
marching my pawn and in any case black
is helpless and just lost alright so
before we end I'll show two more games
one from Korchnoi and the later Karpov
game where Karpov will show how he plays
the end games he plays it pretty well
now in this game this was an earlier
game by coronally against cherish and
black obviously wants to get rid of the
Queens now Viktor Korchnoi will decide
how to continue here White has actually
two options
what should white consider here
okay one is one of them second is to
take on a six I will have to decide
which one favors us as white
yeah or okay hey one was played the
reason
fortunately doesn't take on a six ship
takes a six is the fact that he's not
too keen on seeing this bishop posted on
c4 because if that bishop manages to
drop on c4 you could start pushing the
pawns and black might get enough
counterplay so therefore question of
play is Roque one takes takes and again
this is this rigid type of pawn
structure my is not much better his
structure is very good on the other hand
the reason why it will have very good
winning chances is the fact that these
bonds on b6 and d5 are terrible and
they're very hard to defend so Chi rich
doesn't like the idea of seeing this
rook go ballistic on the seventh rank so
he plays Ruby 8 now it's not yet over
cherish is still fighting so
unfortunately we'll need to find a very
very good move here to stop any kind of
counter play from black
the ship f1 is a way to stop it there's
many ways I have to decide which one is
best
why would you play Bishop d7 looks right
yeah yeah yeah what was your opinion why
would ya indeed Bishop d7 is much more
active and yeah you know first and
foremost stops any kind of Bishop moves
the ship c6 stops the pawn so has the
control over that be v square and also
very powerful paralyzing move by Viktor
Korchnoi King f8 King f1 and now cheer
each realized the King can't come closer
because Bishop c6 wins on the spot so in
fact black is an internal to Smaug
meaning black can't do anything right
now
he's just doomed to wait so gg6 how
should we continue just the king's run
King runs yeah yeah the King just runs
King g7 King big 306 f3 well as we see
Korchnoi loves this idea of advancing
he's central pawns and it sounds also a
very good idea because in general if you
get to connect the past pawn sense as
soon we will see that's near winning or
at least it gives you a hefty advantage
that you could try to milk till win
rugby 7 rock takes a 8 takes rugby
now sadly again there's no such movies
rook d6 cuz chick and you'll part with
your rock so frog d6 I'll just play e5
and when you're rock so ro k 7s played
takes rugby - and now this is a very
professional way of playing an endgame
Korchnoi takes away all the possible
counter play that black could get so the
first defense this pawn chain on h2 + g3
before doing any action ok 3 where
should we go with our king C form
obviously in n games a king is a very
very important piece as it's part of the
attack white wants to support this pawn
on d4 with the king okay for King d5
rook 85 king c6
so we can see this usual way of
slaloming up slaloming up to c6 which is
a usual way to bring your King up in a
rock endgame route k-6 check would be 6
fortunately decides that the King is
worth its well positioned on c6 okay for
check asking where your king wants to be
king f6 check again give me 65 and now
fortunately decides that this deep on is
just so powerful that it's just going to
win the game King takes e5 how should we
continue here this is actually a
critical moment in the position check
it's very important if you can and you
get the chance cut off your opponent's
king and that way the chance of you
winning is very likely King f6 well if
the King goes bee-hind upon I just
starts pushing the pawn and this King
will just be a nuisance
and then the way as usually black would
try to check white and also the king
would be much happier to be in front
than behind so huge plays king of six
rookie two and now this king is
eternally blocked from entering the
Queen side where this pawn resides
Brooksie for King B 5 D 6 rogue D 1 King
C 6 H 5 b7
gig f5 King c7 and there's no real way
of stopping white from marching the pawn
up as if you keep checking I'll still go
King c7 King d8 and then d7 obviously
I'll defend the d6 one along the way and
after that let's see that let's give a
check here here check a go King d8 now
so I can go d7 and if you make some move
I go King e8 and now I promote so
there's no real way for just this one
work to stop me because my king will be
very safe on eh partly due to this rook
on e2 because there's no rookie one
checks ever because it's protected by e2
night the e2 Brooke so black played h5
but after d7 King c7 this is just too
slow and the White King just comes back
in time and will take all the pawns here
on the Queen side
fortunately one that was a very nice way
of showing that in these rigid
structures first you want to create a
bind and then you slowly want to push
your opponent off the board and in fact
it was also very important to create a
pass bond with a 3 E 4 that's one thing
to remember in an endgame especially a
rockin game you want to create
response and last but not least let's
see another big expert on end games and
that's of course Anatoly Karpov d4 d5
it's going to be a very classical system
but again we're not really interested in
the opening phase we're more interested
in the endgame that will arise after
that Bishop d3 c5 a5 and now what usable
plays is a defensive system and he's
trying to hold off Karpov from entering
his position she's trying to hold his
position together and Karpov is trying
to breach breach it so as our rooks are
poised to enter the seventh rank how
should we try to get there anyways
put more pressure on c5 in fact Karpov
chose to take first Knight c5 and chose
a plan to get rid of this good night on
c5 any people
idea for not beats me yeah yeah
Karpov found the most optimal and active
way of getting rid of the c5 Knight 92
94 that's no way
Karpov decided to go Knight e5 and to go
to d3 he wants to occupy bits and pieces
of the D line while also having a firm
control on this line so Queen f6 Knight
d3 rook d8 now you supervise trying to
play for counter play takes takes Queen
e2 Karpov obviously doesn't want to take
care cuz rook takes B 2 and this will be
very painful now because this rook would
become extremely active and Karpov would
take upon that he shouldn't have taken
so Queen e2 rook d7 book c2 so Karpov
first guards against all these tactical
ideas that would be in the way a4 g3 so
slowly white is trying to advance in the
long term Harper wants to attack the
pawn on c5 and this pawn on a 4 but look
how he does it rook d5 game g2 just
slowly improving all his pieces g6 a3
now we see these moves a3 and we saw
this kind of bind moves in the Korchnoi
Karpov game where he played f5 if you
remember just pushing black off the
board also making sure that this bond
will be an eternal weakness and that's
very important h5 Queen f3 and Karpov is
consciously going for the endgame
Queenie 5 Yusupov tries to stop that
idea but that's not gonna happen in this
game as Karpov double attacks on e5 n a4
at the same time Nina for she takes
would be eight rook c5 in Corp of
decides that one pawn up is good enough
for him and he'll go on and try to win
this game now this is a very typical
position known from games like laïkó
Anand
the big difference being it's usually
three against three in those positions
and those are officially considered
drawn but four against four is not drawn
is a win for white King f8 bouquet seven
obviously Karpov doesn't want to see
doesn't want to see a king coming closer
rook a one h4 just blocking any ideas of
just coming down the board with an H for
an h3 King g7 a for King f3 just getting
extra tempies as he can
a5 okay three a six now he pushed his
pawn up to a six because he feels and in
the long term the way to win this
position is to use this a pawn to full
effect and in fact trying to clean it
with the help of the King bouquet - King
D 3 and this is actually the same method
that they try to use in the three
against three and games you push your
pawn up to a six or as far as you can do
it usually not to a seven because that's
often very dryish and just bring the
King over row B seven okay to a seven
and as this rook is very active the
position is very favorable for Karpov
the only thing left to do for him is to
just come up with you the King go behind
it and just promote or just go King b6
and Ruby eight which could be even
better because the closer your king is
to your pawns the more likely black
can't get any country chances so your
superb is trying something trying to
open up the position
but Karpov is on face he takes upon pd6
King c4 g5 he is actually trying to get
some counterplay h4 King b5 rugby - king
c6 some checks King c7 h3 King b8 and
Karpov achieved his goal and after H to
rugby one you super resigned and this is
a very proficient way of playing the end
game he gained every tempi he could get
he blocked the weakness on a4 as we saw
before and it's very meticulous play
Karpov nurses advantage to a win and
that's how you should play rigid
structures thank you
[Music]